hey tommy
how are you tom papa everybody
america's own yeah that's right baby
so see you guys all the stuff that you
see here and tom brought out this flag
and we'll explain you what
so we asked everybody to bring something
that we he can sign
it's from his house that you can bid on
or that thomas in his front yard yeah
exactly
this was last minute
would you just grab anything in the
garage yeah i was in the car
and i went oh [ __ ] the thing i forgot
the thing
and uh i just hit i didn't want to go
back inside because my wife was in there
with
the whole family and i already said
goodbye and once you're out you don't
want to go back
so i'm like there's a garage so i hit
the garage door opener
and the thing opens up i go in there and
i look around
and uh and this hangs uh i have like a
shelf in the garage like if this is the
garage and then there's a shelf
and this hangs here and uh i see the
flag i'm like oh it's but it's my flag
it's like
it hangs and then behind it you hide all
dad's secrets
really yeah like you don't go behind the
flag daddy dude
no you can get hurt get hurt behind
there and they think there's like this
glass or like a chainsaw
constantly running or something well you
got some old wheeze
i got weed i got weed and a little cup
oh i said wheeze
paulie shore back there
yeah polly shores there and uh no i got
i have uh
i have weed i have weed and um
and the fridge is there so there's uh
there's uh beer and stuff and then uh
there's also
meat my whole family's vegetarian so
there's meat
i know it sounds pathetic and sad like i
literally stand there and the like the
from where it hangs to where the
action is is uh it's
it's like this it's literally two and a
half feet well that's just fine
i just stand there like this
and the flag is like here
and i do whatever i gotta do to be happy
i used to have dreams laugh
if you will it is the happiest place on
earth